RULES COMMITTEE MEETING FOR
THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. HE'S BE ADVISED ON
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING
MADE OF TODAY'S PROCEEDING AS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDED THE HEARING
CREWS WERE BASKET ALL TIMES.
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBED
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT THIS HEARING VIOLATION
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
FORCE PROCESS. MISTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE
WALDRON. HERE I HAVE TO HEAR
MORE OF YOUR FONG THERE IT SAYS
HERE ME THERE. NOT. WE'LL BE OUT
HERE YOU CAN WALK HERE. YEAH OUR
- WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A CAN
AGENDA. HOMES AND TO REGAL SIDE
. THIS IS- I'D LIKE TO REMOVE A
COUPLE FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST REMOVAL
OUGHT TO REMOVE THE REFERRAL OF
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR FROM
CONSENT IT CREATES A NEW TAX AND
SHOULD ALSO BE HEARD IN THE
COMMITTEE ON REV AND TAX. AND
ALSO ASKED TO REMOVE ITEM NINE
THE URGENCY REQUEST FOR AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE FROM
CONSENT MEMBERS HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
PROPOSED LANGUAGE. OKAY WE WILL
MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS IS OUR
MOTION REMAINED WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA. WE WERE MAYES RUBIO
SECONDED BY MR FOR MR SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE WALDRON AYE WALDRON
AYE BENNETT BENNETT HI FLORA
FLORA HI FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON HIGHLY THE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MATHIS AYE
RUBIO RUBIO. PUJA THE APPROVED
BY. K. THAT MOTION PASSES- AND
IS THERE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ON. A LET'S START WITH AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR- MOVE BY MR
BENNETT SECONDED BY MR LEE OF
RESTRICTED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE WALDRON NOW
WALDRON KNOW BENNETT. BENNETT HI
FLORA FLORA NO FONG FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON HI LI LI I
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MATHIS NO
RUBIO. RUBIO IV APPROVED BY THE
HAVE MOTIONS PASS IS OUR MOTION
ON THE ADDITION OF THE R. C.
CLAUSE TO AB. TWENTY ONE SEVEN
NINE RECENT- AYE MR GRACE
SECONDED BY MR. OF GIPSON PART
WHAT. IT'S NOT ABOUT SHOULD BE
CORRECT. PARDON ME. OUR RESEARCH
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY. I GREW AYE WALDRON NOT
PHONE WALDRON NOT VOTING THAT.
VENETI FLORA FLORA NO FONG FONG
AYE GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE LEE.
THE AYE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MATHIS NO RUBIO RUBIO I COULD
WELL BE VALLAPUDUA HIGH MOTION
PASSES TO MOTIONS PASSED AND
THIS RULES WAS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.